raymond smallian was a mathematician a
concert pianist a logician a taoist a
magician and a philosopher there are two
people i desperately would like to have
on the show one is douglas hofstetter
and the other is raymond smallian
unfortunately raymond is no longer with
us at least not in his corporeal form
however his writings remain click on the
timestamp in the description if you'd
like to skip this intro for those new to
this channel my name is kurt jaimungle
i'm a filmmaker with a background in
mathematical physics dedicated to the
explication of what are called theories
of everything from a theoretical physics
perspective but as well as delineating
the possible connection consciousness
has to the fundamental laws of nature
provided these laws exist at all and are
even knowable to us what raven smallian
writes about that's of interest to this
channel is rationality god and free will
raymond's cousin jacob smallian reached
out to me to give me his blessing as the
copyright holder to bring you this
excerpt from the tao is silent published
by harper collins in the u.s this is a
conversation between immortal which i'm
going to be calling man and god on the
burden of free will what it means to be
identified with god and what the laws of
nature mean it evokes the same feelings
of playful awe on the most profound
aspects of life that girdle esherbach
elicits now that's one heck of an
achievement so i'd like to dedicate this
episode to raymond smalian thank you for
what you've done man if you enjoy
witnessing and engaging in conversation
on the topics of psychology physics
consciousness and so on then check the
description for an invitation to the
discord and the theories of everything
subreddit there's also a link to the
patreon that is patreon.com
c-u-r-t
j-a-i-m-u-n-g-a-l kercher mungle if
you'd like to support this podcast as
the patrons and the sponsors are the
only reason i'm able to do this
full-time it would be near impossible at
least for me to have conversations on
loop quantum gravity non-dualism
consciousness even geometric unity with
any sort of fidelity if not for your
support thank you and that link again is
patreon.com
kurtjmungle with regard to sponsors
there are two algo is an end-to-end
supply chain optimization software
company with software that helps
business users optimize sales and
operations planning to avoid stockouts
reduce returns and inventory write downs
while reducing inventory investment it's
a supply chain ai that drives smart roi
headed by a bright individual by the
name of amjad hussein who's been a huge
supporter of this podcast since near its
inception the second sponsor is
brilliant brilliant illuminates the soul
of mathematics science and engineering
through bite-sized interactive learning
experiences that explore the laws that
shape our world it elevates math and
science from something to be feared to a
delightful experience of guided
discovery you can even learn group
theory which is what's being referenced
when people say that the standard model
is based upon u1 cross su-2 cross s23
those are technically called lead groups
visit brilliant.org
toe t-o-e for free and get 20 off the
annual subscription i recommend that you
don't stop before four lessons and i
think you'll be greatly surprised at the
ease at which you can now comprehend
subjects that you previously had
difficulty grocking thank you and enjoy
this excerpt called god is a taoist by
raymond smallian i'll do my best to
preface my commentary with the word
commentary because if you're viewing
this on youtube it's probably obvious
when i'm commenting just based on my
body language and intonation but i
realize that it's equivocal for those
who are on the audio platforms i also
know that the word taoist is pronounced
taoist
but for whatever reason that feels
disingenuous to me saying it it feels
affected on my part let's get to it
man says and therefore oh god i pray
thee if thou has one ounce of mercy for
this thy suffering creature absolve me
of having to have free will
god says you reject the greatest gift
i've given thee
man how can i call that which has been
forced onto me a gift i have free will
but not of my own free will not of my
own choice i have never thus freely
chosen to have free will i have to have
free will whether i like it or not
god why would you wish to not have free
will man because free will means moral
responsibility and moral responsibility
is more than i can bear commentary
some people are burdened by guilt guilt
that they haven't achieved what they
should
guilt that they've done horrible acts in
the past that they think they shouldn't
have now one solution is when this comes
from the eastern end the more
non-duelist and is that well we
eradicate free will that is tell someone
there exists no free will and then they
couldn't have done otherwise and another
route is to eradicate morality
altogether because implicit in what i've
said before or somewhat explicit is the
word should while some of those on the
more eastern end will criticize the
western end by saying you want to
preserve free will because you have an
ego and your ego wants to say for
example that you're responsible for the
successful position in life that you're
in you'll want to bolster your
self-image and minimize the role of
happenstance however there's the twin
motivation on the other side of not
wanting to feel the crushing weight of
free will
so it's not as if one side is immune
from ulterior motives perhaps your life
is so hard so terrible so crushing in
terms of the weight of free will and so
on that you have an unconscious
motivation to believe that there doesn't
exist it
back to the dialogue
god why do you find moral responsibility
so unbearable man why i honestly can't
analyze why all i know is that i do god
all right in that case i absolve you of
all your moral responsibility but leave
you still with having free will so will
this be satisfactory man no i'm afraid
not he says after a pause
god says
ah just as i thought so moral
responsibility isn't the only aspect of
free will that you object to
what else is it about free will that's
bothering you man
with free will i'm capable of sinning
and i don't want to sin
god if you don't want to sin then why do
you man good god i don't know why i want
to sin i just do evil temptations come
along and try as i can i cannot resist
them
god okay well if it's true you can't
resist them then you're not sinning of
your own free will and hence according
to me at least that's not sinning at all
man
no no i keep feeling that if only i
tried harder i could avoid sinning i
understand that the will is infinite
if one wholeheartedly wills not to sin
then one won't sin
god
well now you should know do you try as
hard as you can to avoid sinning or
don't you
i honestly don't know at the time i feel
like i'm trying as hard as i can but in
retrospect i'm worried that i maybe
didn't
god so in other words you don't know
whether or not you've been sinning the
possibility is open that you haven't
been sinning at all man of course the
possibility is open but maybe i have
been sinning and this thought is what so
frightens me
god
why does the thought of sinning frighten
you man i don't know why for one you do
have a reputation for medding out rather
gruesome punishments in the afterlife
god
okay so that's what's bothering you why
didn't you say so in the first place
with all this peripheral talk of free
will and responsibility why didn't you
simply request to me to not punish you
for your sins
man well i'm realistic enough to know
that you would hardly grant such a
request god you don't say you have a
realistic knowledge of what requests i
grant eh
it's canadian
well i'll tell you what i'm going to do
i'm going to grant you a very very
special dispensation to sin as much as
you like and i will give you my divine
word of honor that i will never punish
you in the least agreed
man in great terror no no no no don't do
that god
why not don't you trust my divine word
man of course i do but don't you see i
don't want to sin i have an utter
abhorrence of sinning quite apart from
any punishments it may entail god in
that case i'll do you one better i'll
remove your abhorrence of sinning
here is a magic pill just swallow it and
you'll lose all abhorrence of sinning
you will joyfully and merely sin away
you will have no regrets no abhorrence
and i still promise you will never be
punished by me
or yourself or by any source whatsoever
you will be blissful for all eternity so
here it is here is the pill man no no
god are you not being irrational i am
even removing your abhorrence of sin
which is your last obstacle
man i still won't take it god why not
man i believe that the pill will indeed
remove my future abhorrence of sinning
but my present abhorrence is enough to
prevent me from being willing to take it
god i command you to take it man i
refuse
god
you refuse of your own free will man yes
ah god says so it seems that your free
will comes in pretty handy doesn't it
man i don't understand god aren't you
glad now that you have the free will to
refuse such a ghastly offer how would
you like it if i forced you to take this
pill whether you wanted it or not
commentary see it's unclear what free
will is defined as some people would say
it's if you go backward in time which we
have to presume that's even possible you
could have done differently
it seems like the more you analyze the
definition of free will the more that it
slips through your fingers however
that's true of many of the most
significant aspects of our lives and it
doesn't mean that we shouldn't
investigate it same with consciousness
the more one talks about consciousness
the more one seems to describe it in
words that are synonyms with
consciousness like experience or
awareness but that to me doesn't mean
that we shouldn't continue to dialogue
about it for example for many years the
word energy the word length and speed
and so on didn't have exact precise
definitions it wasn't until physics
came about or the rudiments of physics
however all of this preliminary
conversation with these indistinct words
are what led to the words becoming
distinct later it's not as if physics
emerged from a vacuum now you may say
that well physics came about once
rationality was applied however
rationality didn't emerge from a vacuum
either on a recent conversation with
jonathan blow on this channel he
indicates that the word free will is
somewhat meaningless i don't think so i
think it may be meaningless currently
but i don't think talking about it is
useless
man no no no please don't feed me this
pill god of course i won't i'm just
trying to illustrate a point
all right let me put it this way instead
of forcing you to take this pill suppose
i grant your original prayer of removing
your free will but with the
understanding that the moment you are no
longer free
then you will take the pill
man
once my will is gone how can i possibly
choose to take the pill god i didn't say
you would choose it i merely said you
would take it you would act let us say
according to purely deterministic laws
which are such that you would as a
matter of fact take it
man i still refuse
god so you refuse my offer to remove
your free will this is rather different
from your original prayer isn't it
man now i see what you're up to your
argument is ingenious but i'm not sure
it's really correct there are some
points that we have to go over again god
certainly
man there are two things you said which
seem contradictory to me first you said
that one cannot sin unless one does so
of one's own free will but then you said
you can give me a pill that would
deprive me of my free will and then i
could sin as much as i like however if i
had no free will according to your first
statement how could i possibly be
capable of sinning
god you are confusing two separate parts
of our conversation i never said the
pill would deprive you of free will but
only that it would remove your
abhorrence of sinning
man
i'm a bit confused god all right then
let's make a fresh start suppose i agree
to remove your free will
but with the understanding that you will
then commit an enormous number of acts
which you now regard as sinful
technically speaking you will not then
be sinning since you will not be doing
these acts of your own free will and
these acts carry no moral responsibility
no moral culpability nor any punishment
whatsoever nevertheless these acts will
all be of the type which you presently
regard as sinful they will all have this
quality which you presently feel as
abhorrent but your abhorrence will
disappear
so you will not then feel abhorrent
toward the act man no but i have a
present abhorrence toward the acts and
this present abhorrence is sufficient to
prevent me from accepting your proposal
god god says hmm okay let me get this
absolutely straight i take it you no
longer wish for me to remove your free
will man reluctantly says no i guess not
god all right i agree not to but i'm
still not exactly clear as to why you no
longer wish to get rid of your free will
so please tell me again man because as
you've told me without free will i would
sin even more than i do now
god
but i've already told you that without
free will you cannot sin
man
but if i choose now to get rid of my
free will then all my subsequent evil
actions will not be sins not of the
future but of the present moment in
which i choose not to have free will god
sounds like you're pretty badly trapped
doesn't it
man of course i'm trapped you've placed
this hideous double blind on me now
whatever i do is wrong if i retain free
will i will continue to sin if i abandon
my free will with your help of course i
will now be sinning in doing so
god
but by the same token you place me in a
double bind i am willing to leave you
with free will or to remove it as you
choose but neither alternative satisfies
you i wish to help you but it seems like
i cannot man true god but since it's not
my fault why are you still angry with me
man
for having placed me in such a horrible
predicament in the first place
commentary
in the video that i have with leo gura i
talk about atheists and how it doesn't
seem like atheists disbelieve in god
necessarily it seems like they in fact
dislike god or dislike god if god were
to exist because in their mind if god
was to exist what kind of god would
allow the torturing of a child or
animals or the raping of mothers in
front of their children and live
vivisections on
thousands of people if not tens of
thousands if not
worse and worse and worse you can see
this with the problem of evil
in some ways i analogize this to
thinking that one knows better than god
because the problem of evil let's say to
call it the problem of evil implies that
you believe you have a better
understanding of what good is than god
himself it implies that your current
knowledge is sufficient enough for you
to make an authoritative determination
to say what is good and what is evil all
of this is to say while it may be
obvious to many people it's not obvious
to me exactly what the difference is
between disbelieving in god and
despising god
getting back to the conversation
god okay it sounds like you're pretty
badly trapped doesn't it man you've
placed me in this horrible predicament
in the first place god but according to
you there's nothing satisfactory i could
have done man you mean there's nothing
satisfactory you can do now that doesn't
mean there's nothing you could have done
god
why
what could i have done man
obviously you should never have given me
free will in the first place now that
you've given it to me it is too late
anything i do will be bad but you should
never have given it to me in the first
place
god
why would it be better for me to have
never given you free will man because
then i would never have been capable of
sinning
god well
i'm always glad to learn from my
mistakes man what
god
i know that sounds sort of self
blasphemous doesn't it it almost
involves a logical paradox on the one
hand as you've been taught it is morally
wrong for any sentient being to claim
that i am capable of making mistakes on
the other hand i have the right to do
anything but i'm also a sentient being
so the question is do i or do i not have
the right to claim that i'm capable of
making mistakes
commentary there are some philosophers
who think that god is incapable of
making a logical contradiction which
means that logic is imposed upon god
which implies constraints on god that
are not god unless you want to make an
equivalence between god and logic which
some do logos is the root of logic
there's also the school of thought that
it's not blasphemous to think that god
can't do a logical contradiction it's
not as if this is a subtle debate
getting back to the text
man that is a bad joke one of your
premises is simply false i have not been
taught that it is wrong for any sentient
being to doubt your omniscience but only
for a mortal to doubt it
but since you're not mortal
then you're obviously free from this
injunction god good so you realize this
on a rational level nevertheless you did
appear shocked when i said i'm glad to
learn from my mistakes
man of course i was shocked i was
shocked not by yourself blasphemous
behavior as you jokingly called it not
by the fact that you had no right to say
it but just by the fact that you did say
it since i've been taught that as a
matter of fact you don't make mistakes
so i was amazed that you claim it's
possible for you to make mistakes god i
have not claimed that it's possible all
i am saying is that if i were to make
mistakes i will be happy to learn from
them but this says nothing about whether
the if has or ever can be realized
man stop quibbling about this point do
you or do you not admit that it was a
mistake to have given me free will
god well now this is precisely what i
want to propose we should investigate
let me review your present predicament
you don't want to have free will because
with free will you can sin and you don't
want to sin on the other hand if you
agreed to give up free will then you
would now be responsible for the acts of
the future ergo i should never have
given you the free will in the first
place man exactly god i understand
exactly how you feel many mortals even
some theologians have complained that
i've been rather unfair in that it was i
not they who decided that they should
have free will and then hold them
responsible for their actions in other
words they feel that they're expected to
live up to a contract with me which they
never agreed to in the first place man
exactly god as i said i understand the
feeling perfectly and i can appreciate
the justice of the complaint but the
complaints only arise from an
unrealistic understanding of the true
issues involved i am about to enlighten
you as to what these are and i think the
results will surprise you but instead of
telling you outright i shall continue to
use the socratic method
to repeat you regret that i've ever
given you free will i claim that when
you see the true ramifications you will
no longer have this regret to prove my
point i'll tell you what i'm going to do
i am about to create a new universe a
new space-time continuum
in this new universe you will be born a
man a mortal just like you for all
practical purposes we may say you are
being reborn now i can give this new
mortal this new you free will or not
what would you like me to do
man in great relief says okay please
spare him of having the free will
god
all right i'll do as you say
but you do realize that this new you
without free will will commit all sorts
of horrible acts man
but they will not be sins since you will
have no free will god
whether you call them sins or not the
fact remains that they will be horrible
acts in the sense that they will cause
great pain to many sentient beings
man after a long pause
good god you have trapped me again
always the same game if i now give you
the go-ahead to create this new creature
with no free will who will nevertheless
commit atrocious acts then true enough
he will not be sinning but i will be the
sinner to sanction this god
in that case i'll do you one better here
i have already decided whether to create
this new you this reborn you with free
will or not
now i am writing my decision on this
piece of paper i shall not show you this
paper until later but my decision is now
made absolutely and irrevocably there is
nothing you can do nothing you can do to
alter it you have no responsibility in
this matter
now which way do you hope i have decided
remember now the responsibility for the
decision falls entirely on my shoulders
not yours so
you can tell me perfectly honestly
without any fear which way do you hope i
have decided man says after a very long
pause
i hope you have decided to give him free
will
god
most interesting i have removed your
last obstacle if i do not give him free
will there is no sin to be imputed to
anybody
so why do you hope that i give him free
will
man because sin or no sin the important
point is that if you do not give him
free will then
at least according to what you said he
will go around hurting people
and i don't want to see people hurt
god with an infinite sigh of relief
at last at last you see the real point
man
what point is that god that sinning is
not the real issue
the important thing is that other
sentient beings do not get hurt man you
sound like a utilitarian god i am a
utilitarian man what god
what's or no what i am a utilitarian
not a unitarian mind you but a
utilitarian
man i just can't believe that god
yes i know your religious training has
taught you otherwise you've probably
thought of me more like a kantian in the
sense of immanuel kent than a
utilitarian but your training was simply
wrong
man you leave me speechless god
i leave you speechless do i well that's
perhaps not too bad of a thing you have
a tendency to speak too much as it is
seriously though why do you think i ever
gave you free will in the first place
man why did you
i never thought much about why you did
it all i've been arguing is that you
shouldn't have
but
why did you
i guess all i can think of is the
religious explanation without free will
one is not capable of meriting either
salvation or damnation so without free
will one cannot earn the right to
eternal life
god says most interesting i have eternal
life
do you think i have done anything to
merit that eternal life
man of course not but with you it's
different you're already so good and
perfect
at least allegedly that it's not
necessary for you to merit eternal life
god really now that puts me into a
rather enviable position doesn't it man
i don't think i understand you god
here i am eternally blissful without
ever having to suffer or make sacrifices
or struggle against evil temptations or
anything like that without any of that
type of merit i enjoy a blissful eternal
existence
by contrast you poor mortals have to
sweat and suffer and have all sorts of
horrible conflicts about morality
and all for what
you don't even know whether or not i
exist
or if there's any afterlife no matter
how much you try to placate me by being
good you never have any real assurance
that your best is good enough for me and
hence no real security in obtaining
salvation just think of it
i already have the equivalent of
salvation and i've never had to go
through the infinitely luxurious process
of earning it
don't you ever envy me for this man
but it's blasphemous to envy you god oh
come off it you're not talking to your
sunday school teacher you're talking to
me blasphemous or not the important
question is not whether or not you have
a right to be envious of me but whether
or not you are
are you man of course i am
commentary
i wonder how much of
the whole debate as to whether or not
god exists comes from people who are
envious of god
so are atheists envious of god by the
way i'm not an atheist nor am i a theist
at least i wouldn't classify myself as
either an atheist or a theist i'm unsure
and speculating in this regard though i
am driven by the statement which says
that we mortals scorn what we valiantly
strive for but do not obtain
that is we mortals scorn what we
valiantly strive for but don't obtain
back to the text
man of course i'm jealous of you
god good under your present world view
you should be most envious of me but i
think with a more realistic worldview
you will no longer be so you really have
swallowed this idea that's been taught
to you that your life on earth is like
an examination period and the purpose of
providing you with free will is to test
you to see if you merit a blissful
eternal life but what puzzles me is this
if you really believe i am as good and
benevolent as i'm cracked up to be
why should i require that people merit
things like happiness or eternal life
why should i not just grant that to
everyone regardless of if they deserve
it
man
but i've been taught that you have a
sense of morality you have a sense of
justice that demands goodness be
rewarded with happiness and evil be
punished with pain god
then you've been taught wrong
man but the religious literature is so
full of this idea take for example
jonathan edwards sinners in the hand of
an angry god how he describes you as
holding your enemies like loathsome
scorpions over the flaming pit of hell
preventing them from falling into the
fate that they deserve only by dint of
your mercy
god
fortunately i have not been exposed to
the tirades of mr jonathan edwards
few sermons have ever been preached
which are more misleading
the very title sinners in the hands of
an angry god tells its own tale in the
first place i am never angry in the
second place i do not think at all in
terms of sin in the third place i have
no enemies man
by that do you mean that there are no
people whom you hate or there are no
people who hate you
god i meant the former although the
latter also happens to be true
man oh come now i know people who openly
claim to have hated you or at times i
have even hated you
god
you mean you have hated your image of me
and that's not the same as hating what i
really am
man are you saying that it's not wrong
to hate a false conception of you but it
is wrong to hate you as you really are
god no i'm not saying that at all what i
am saying is far more drastic what i'm
saying has absolutely nothing with right
or wrong what i'm saying is that one who
knows me for what i truly am will find
it psychologically impossible to hate me
commentary tyler goodstein made this
point his channel is linked in the
description
that perhaps if you find no evidence of
god or perhaps even if you hate god you
should revise your definition of god and
that's extremely interesting because the
way that we're taught to think as
rational people is you start with the
definition then you go looking for the
evidence this says rather than starting
with your definition then looking for
evidence and then subsequently
dismissing the idea of god the fact that
you dismiss the idea or that you don't
find god indicates that you need to have
a reassessment of your definition
while i find that extremely interesting
back to the text
to recapitulate god what i am saying is
that if one knows me for what i truly am
one would find it psychologically
impossible to hate me man tell me
since we mortals seem to have such an
erroneous view
about your real nature
why don't you enlighten us
why don't you guide us the right way
god
what makes you think i'm not
man
i mean
why don't you appear to our very senses
and simply tell us
that we're wrong
god
are you really so naive as to believe
that i am the sort of being which can
appear to your senses
it would be more correct to say that i
am your senses man who's astonished says
you are my senses god not quite i am
more than that but it comes closer to
the truth than that i am perceivable to
your senses i am not an object like you
i am a subject i am a subject that can
perceive but cannot be perceived you can
no more see me than you can see your own
thoughts
you can see an apple but the event of
you seeing an apple is itself not
seeable and i am far more like the
seeing of an apple than i am like the
apple itself
man if i cannot see you how do i know
you exist god good question how in fact
do you know i exist man
well i am talking to you am i not god
how do you know that you're talking to
me let's suppose you told your
psychiatrist yesterday i talked to god
what do you think that psychiatrist
would say
what do you think they would say
man well that might depend on the
psychiatrist most of them are atheistic
so i guess they would tell me i'm simply
talking to myself god and they would be
right man you mean you don't exist god
you have the strangest faculty of
drawing false conclusions just because
you are talking to yourself it follows
that i don't exist man well if i think
i'm talking to you but i in fact i'm
talking to myself then in what sense do
you exist god
god your question is based on two
fallacies plus a confusion the question
of whether or not you're now talking to
me and the question of whether or not
you and i are totally separate even if
you are not now talking to me which
obviously you are it still wouldn't mean
that i don't exist man well i'll write
of course
so instead of saying if i'm talking to
myself then you don't exist i should
have rather said if i am talking to
myself then i obviously am not talking
to you
god
that's a very different statement indeed
but still false man oh come on if i'm
only talking to myself how can i be
talking to you
god
your use of the word only is quite
misleading i can suggest several logical
possibilities under which you talking to
yourself doesn't imply that you're not
talking to me
man suggest just one god well obviously
one such possibility is that you and i
are identical man that's such a
blasphemous thought at least it would be
had i uttered it god oh yes according to
some religions though according to
others it's plain simple immediately
perceived as the truth
man so the only way out of my dilemma is
to believe that you and i are identical
god
not at all this is only one way out
there are several others for example it
may be that you're a part of me in which
case you may be talking to the part of
me which is you or that maybe i'm a part
of you in which case you may be talking
to that part of you which is me or again
you and i might partially overlap in
which case you may be talking to the
intersection and hence talking to both
you and to me
the only way you're talking to yourself
might seem to imply that you're not
talking to me is if you and i were
totally disjoint and even then you could
conceivably be talking to both of us
man so you claim you do exist
god not at all again you draw false
conclusions the question of my existence
has not even come up all i have said is
from the fact that you are talking to
yourself one cannot possibly infer my
non-existence let alone the weaker fact
that you are not talking to me
man all right i'll grant you your point
but what i really want to know is do you
exist
god what a strange question man why
men have been asking this for countless
millennia god i know that the question
itself is not strange what i mean is
that it's strange of you to ask that of
me man why god because i'm the very one
whose existence you doubt
i perfectly well understand your anxiety
you are worried that your present
experience with me is a mere
hallucination but how can you possibly
expect to obtain reliable information
from a being about that being's
existence when you suspect the
non-existence of that very same being
man
so you won't tell me whether or not you
exist
god i am not being willful
i am merely wishing to point out to you
that no one could possibly give you an
answer that would satisfy you all right
suppose i said no i don't exist well
what would that prove absolutely nothing
or perhaps i said yes i do exist
would that convince you of course not
man says
well if you can't tell me whether or not
you exist then who possibly can
god
that is something that no one can tell
you
it is something which only you can find
out for yourself
man
how do i go about finding this out for
myself
god
that also no one can tell you
this is another thing you will have to
find out for yourself
commentary
about this channel the name is theories
of everything which is an audacious goal
to explain everything well firstly there
are many different interpretations of
what it means to be a theory of
everything one is physics one is a
reductionist account to explain all
phenomenon which sounds like a physics
term but it depends if you think physics
is the be all in and all but i think a
better way to understand this channel is
to think of it in terms of an
exploration or a search for the answers
to large mysteries
as well as what those mysteries are
the reason i say that last point is
because it's not clear exactly what
consciousness is we still need a refined
definition it's not clear you can even
define it because some people think that
consciousness is the same as all and so
to define means to delimit and you can't
limit all back to the text
man so there's no way you can help me
find out whether or not you exist or how
to find out whether or not you exist god
i didn't say that i said there's no way
i can tell you but that doesn't mean
there's no way i can help you man in
what manner then can you help me
god
i suggest you leave that to me we've
gotten sidetracked as it is and i'd like
to return to the question of what you
believed my purpose to be in giving you
free will your first idea of me giving
you free will was in order to test
whether or not you merit salvation or
damnation
but that idea is quite hideous to me you
cannot think of any nicer reason any
more humane reason why i gave you free
will
man well i once asked this question of
an orthodox rabbi
he told me that the way were constituted
is that it's simply not impossible for
us to enjoy salvation unless we've
earned it and to earn it we of course
need free will
god that explanation is indeed much
nicer than the former but it's still far
from correct according to orthodox
judaism i created angels and they have
no free will they are an actual sight of
me and so are completely attracted to my
goodness such that they never even have
the slightest temptation toward evil
they really have no choice in the matter
yet they're eternally happy even though
they've never earned it so if your
rabbi's explanation was correct why
wouldn't i have simply created angels
rather than mortals
man beats me why didn't you god
because the explanation is simply not
correct in the first place i've never
created any ready-made angels all
sentient beings ultimately approach the
state that we might call angelhood but
just as the race of human beings or the
species of human beings is in a certain
stage of biological evolution so angels
are simply the end result of a process
of cosmic evolution the only difference
between the so-called saint and the
so-called sinner is that the former is
vastly older than the latter
unfortunately it takes countless life
cycles to learn what is perhaps the most
important fact of the universe
evil is simply painful
all the arguments of the moralists all
the alleged reasons why people should or
shouldn't commit evil acts simply pale
into insignificance in light of this one
basic truth that evil is suffering
no my dear friend i am not a moralist i
am wholly a utilitarian
that i'm conceived in the role of a
moralist is one of the great tragedies
of the human race my role in the scheme
of things
if one can use this misleading
expression is neither to punish nor
reward but to aid the process by which
all sentient beings achieve ultimate
perfection
man
why did you say your expression is
misleading
god
what i said was misleading in two
respects firstly it's inaccurate to
speak of my role in the scheme of things
i am the scheme of things
secondly it's equally misleading to
speak of my aiding the process of
sentient beings attaining enlightenment
i am the process the ancient taoists
were quite close when they said of me
whom they called the tau
that i do not do things yet through me
all things get done
in more modern terms i am not the cause
of a cosmic process i am the cosmic
process itself i think the most accurate
and fruitful definition of me which man
can frame
at least in his present state of
evolution is that i am the very process
of enlightenment those who wish to think
of the devil although i wish they
wouldn't
might analogously define him as the
unfortunate length of time that that
process takes
in this sense the devil is necessary
the process simply does take an
inordinate amount of time and there's
absolutely nothing i can do about that
but i assure you once that process is
more correctly understood the painful
length of time will no longer be
regarded as an essential limitation or
an evil it will simply be seen as the
very essence of the process itself i
know this is not completely consoling to
you who are now in the finite sea of
suffering but the amazing thing is that
once you grasp this fundamental attitude
your very finite suffering will begin to
diminish ultimately to the vanishing
point
man
yes i've been told this and
i tend to believe it
but suppose i personally succeed in
seeing things through your eternal eyes
then i will be happier but don't i have
a duty to others
god laughing
you remind me of the mahayana buddhists
each one says i will never enter nirvana
until i see that every other sentient
being does so so each one waits until
the other fellow goes first
no wonder it takes them so long the
hinayana buddhists air in a different
direction they believe that no one can
be of the slightest help to others in
obtaining salvation each one has to do
it entirely by themselves and so each
one tries for their own salvation but
this detached attitude makes salvation
impossible the truth of the matter is
that salvation is partially an
individual and partly a social process
but it is a grave mistake to believe as
do many mahayana buddhists that the
attaining of enlightenment puts one out
of commission so to speak for helping
others
the best way of helping others
is by first seeing the light
oneself
man
there is one thing about your
self-description which is somewhat
disturbing
you describe yourself essentially as a
process this puts you in such an
impersonal light and so many people have
a need for a personal god
god
so just because they need a personal god
it follows that i am one
man of course not but to be acceptable
to immortal a religion must satisfy his
needs god i realize that but this
so-called personality of a being is
really more in the eyes of the beholder
than in the being itself
the controversies which have raged about
whether or not i am a personal or an
impersonal being are rather silly
because neither side is right or wrong
from one point of view i'm personal from
another i'm not
it's the same with a human being a
creature from another planet may look at
that human purely impersonally as a mere
collection of particles according to
which they act strictly to prescribe
physical law that alien may have no more
feeling for the personality of the human
than the average human does for an ant
yet the ant has just as much an
individual personality as a human to
beings like myself who really know the
ant to look at something impersonally is
no more correct or incorrect than to
look at it personally but in general the
better you get to know something the
more personal it becomes to illustrate
my point
do you think of me as a personal or an
impersonal being
man well i am talking to you am i not
god exactly now from that point of view
your attitude toward me might be
described as a personal one and yet from
another point of view no less valid
i can also be looked at impersonally man
but if you're really such an abstract
thing as a process i don't see
how i can make sense of what it means to
talk to a mere process
god i love how you say the word mir
you might as well just say you're living
in a mere universe
also why must everything one does make
sense
does it make sense to talk to a tree man
of course not god
and yet many children and primitives do
just that
man well i'm neither a child nor a
primitive
god i realize that unfortunately man
why unfortunately god because many
children and primitives have a primal
intuition which the likes of you have
lost
frankly i think it would do you a lot of
good to talk to a tree every once in a
while even more good than talking to me
but we do seem to be getting sidetracked
let's get back to why i gave you free
will
man i have been thinking about this all
the while god you mean you haven't been
paying attention during a conversation
man of course i have but all the while
on another level i have been thinking
about why did you give me free will god
okay have you come to a conclusion
man
well
you say that the reason is not to test
our worthiness
and you disclaimed that the reason is
that we need to feel that we merit some
things in order to enjoy them and you
claim to be a utilitarian most
significant of all you also appeared so
delighted when it came to the sudden
realization that it is not sinning in
itself which is bad but the suffering
which it causes
god well of course
what else could be conceivably bad about
sinning
man all right you know that now i know
that
but all my life i unfortunately have
been under the influence of moralists
who hold sinning to be bad in itself
anyway putting all these pieces together
it occurs to me that the only reason you
gave free will is because of your belief
that with free will people will tend to
hurt each other
and themselves less than without free
will
god
bravo that is by far the best reason you
have yet given i can assure you that had
i chosen to give you free will that
would have been my very reason for doing
so man what you're saying that you did
not choose to give me free will god my
dear fellow
i could no more choose to give you
free will
then i could choose to make an
equilateral triangle equiangular i could
choose to make or not to make an
equilateral triangle in the first place
but then once i've chosen to make one i
no longer have the choice but to make it
equiangular
man i thought you could do anything god
only things that are logically possible
as saint thomas said it is a sin to
regard the fact that god cannot do the
impossible as a limitation on his powers
i agree except in
the fact that i wouldn't use the term
sin i would use the term error man
anyway i'm still puzzled by your
implication that you did not choose to
give me free will
god well it's high time that i inform
you that this entire discussion from the
very beginning has been based on one
monstrous fallacy
we have been talking purely on a moral
level you originally complained that i
gave you free will and raised the whole
question as to whether or not i should
have it never occurred to you that i had
absolutely no choice in the matter
man
i am still in the dark
god absolutely
because you're only able to look at it
through the eyes of a moralist the more
fundamental metaphysical aspects of the
question you never even considered man i
still don't see what you're driving at
god before you requested me to remove
your free will
shouldn't your first question have been
whether
as a matter of fact that you do have
free will
man well i simply took that for granted
god but why should you man i don't know
do i have free will god yes
man then why would you say that i
shouldn't have taken it for granted god
because you shouldn't just because
something happens to be true it doesn't
follow that it should be taken for
granted
man anyway it's reassuring to know that
my natural intuition about having free
will is correct
sometimes i've been worried that the
determinists are correct god
they are correct man
wait a minute now do i have free will or
don't i god i told you that you do but
that doesn't mean determinism is
incorrect man
well are my acts determined by the laws
of nature or are not they god
the word determined here is a subtle but
powerfully misleading one and has
contributed so much to the confusion of
the free will versus determinism
controversies
your acts are certainly in accordance
with the laws of nature
but to say that they are determined by
the laws of nature creates a totally
misleading psychological image which is
that your will could somehow be in
conflict with the laws of nature and
that the latter is somehow more powerful
than you and could determine your acts
whether you liked it or not
but it's simply impossible for your will
to ever be in conflict with natural law
you and natural law are really one and
the same
man
what do you mean that i cannot conflict
with nature suppose i become very
stubborn and i determine not to obey the
laws of nature
what could stop me if i became
sufficiently stubborn
even you could not stop me god you're
absolutely right i certainly could not
stop you nothing could stop you but
there is no need to stop you because you
couldn't even start as gurtha very
beautifully expressed it in trying to
oppose nature
we are in the very process of doing so
acting in accordance with the laws of
nature
don't you see that the so-called laws of
nature are nothing more than a
description of how you and other beings
do act they are merely a description of
how you act not a prescription of how
you should act not a power or a force
which compels or determines your acts to
be valid allah of nature must take into
account how you in fact do act or if you
like how you choose to act
man so you really claim that i am
incapable
of determining to act against natural
law god
it is interesting that you have twice
now used the phrase determined to act
and chosen to act
this identification is quite common one
often uses the statement i am determined
to do this synonymously with the
statement i have chosen to do this this
very psychological identification should
reveal that determinism and choice are
much closer than they may appear
of course you might as well say that the
doctrine of free will says that it is
you who are doing the determining
whereas the doctrine of determinism
appears to say that you are determined
by something apparently outside you but
this confusion is largely caused by this
bifurcation of reality into the you and
to the not you
really now just where do you leave off
and the rest of the universe begin or
equivalently where does the rest of the
universe leave off and you begin once
you can see that this so-called you and
so-called nature is a continuous whole
then you'll never again be bothered by
such questions as to whether or not it's
you controlling nature or nature
controlling you
thus the muddle of free will versus
determinism will vanish if i may use a
crude analogy imagine two bodies moving
toward each other by virtue of
gravitational attraction
which one is exerting the force on the
other each body if sentient would say
that it's the other exerting the force
but in a way it both is in another way
it is neither it is best to say that it
is the configuration of the two which is
crucial
man
you said a short while ago that our
whole discussion was based on a
monstrous fallacy
you still haven't told me what that
fallacy is
god
why the idea that i possibly could have
created you without free will
you acted as if this was a genuine
possibility and wondered why didn't i
choose it it never occurred to you that
a sentient being without free will is no
more conceivable than a physical object
which exerts no gravitational attraction
bracket there is incidentally more
analogy here than you realize between a
physical object exerting a gravitational
attraction and a sentient being exerting
free will close bracket
can you honestly even imagine a
conscious being without free will what
on earth could that be like i think one
thing in your life that is so misled you
is that i've given man the gift of free
will
as if i first created man and then as an
afterthought endowed him with the
property of free will maybe you think i
have some paint brush with which i
dobbed some creatures with free will and
not others no free will is not an extra
it is part and parcel of the very
essence of consciousness
a conscious being without free will is
simply a metaphysical absurdity
man then why did you play along with me
all this while discussing what i thought
was a moral problem when as you say my
basic confusion
was metaphysical
god
because i thought this would be good
therapy for you
i thought it'd be good therapy for you
to get some moral poison out of your
system
much of your metaphysical confusion was
due to faulty moral notions and so the
latter had to be dealt with first
and now we must part at least until you
need me again
i think our present union will do much
to sustain you for a long while but do
remember what i told you about the trees
of course you don't have to literally
talk to them if doing so makes you feel
let's say silly
but there is much more you can learn
from them as well as from the rocks and
the streams and other aspects of nature
there is nothing like a naturalistic
orientation to dispel all these morbid
thoughts of sin and free will and moral
responsibility at one stage of history
such notions were actually useful i
refer to the days when tyrants had
unlimited power and nothing short of
fears of hell could possibly restrain
them
but man has grown up since then
and this gruesome way of thinking is no
longer necessary
it might be helpful for you to recall
what i once said through the writings of
the great zen poet saying son
if you want to get the plain truth
be not concerned with right and wrong
the conflict between right and wrong
is the sickness
of the mind
i hope you enjoyed this reading of is
god a taoist by raymond smallian
if you'd like to hear more commentary
like this slash readings more
conversations like this though i tend to
have conversations with people rather
than reading them
then please do consider going to
patreon.com slash kurt jaimungle
it's the patrons as well as the sponsors
that help me do this
on a full-time basis
i wouldn't be able to go in depth with
people on conv i wouldn't be able to
speak to people
in depth at all on let's say loop
quantum gravity or string theory or
consciousness or have out five hour six
hour long conversations with for example
leo gura if not for your support
so please
if you're interested in helping support
this channel then do go to patreon.com
slash kirkjamongle in the description
there's a paypal option for one-time
donations there's also a crypto address
thank you for your viewership regardless
of whatever it is that you choose
commentary
the reason why i love raymond smalian is
this is such a playful conversation and
to me it captures plenty of the
unconscious thoughts that we have or
perhaps even conscious that we've never
verbalized out loud at least that we
have about god
you